MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm
here with Bob from SeMI
and today we're talking
all about knowledge graphs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
How do they actually get
the, well, Weaviate set up?
BOB VAN LUIJT:
Yeah, so there are
two ways how you can do that.
So one is if you want to try
it out or play around with it,
we have Docker
containers available,
so you can run it even
on your local machine.
But if you want to scale it to--
for big use cases, we have Helm
Charts and Kubernetes classes
ready that you can just--
with the push of a button,
you can run it out of the box.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So let's
talk about the first case,
where they just have
a Docker container.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: How
is it available to them,
and then what should
they do with it?
BOB VAN LUIJT: One
of the things that we
do is that we have
the machinery model.
So that is pre-trained.
That lives on Docker Hub.
Also Weaviate itself
lives on Docker Hub.
So you just literally
run a Docker Compose app,
and you get everything, and
then you start running it.
There's really nothing
more that you have to do.
And a question that I get lots--
people ask me, like, yeah, but
where do I need to train it?
And the answer is, you don't.
We'll make sure that's
all happening for you.
We train it on there.
We train it on Google Cloud.
We deploy it to Docker Hub.
That's it.
It's just you click
Docker Compose app,
take a sip of coffee,
and you're good to go.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So all of
that made available to them?
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
then the second model
is you're kind of hosting
that for them, right?
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yes,
that is correct.
So we also host it for them.
Which, to be honest,
under the hood,
it's pretty much the same thing.
So it really depends
on what people want.
So they can use the
open source version,
do everything themselves.
They can use the hosted version,
where we host it for them.
Or, we have a model
where we say we
help you set it up on,
for example, Google Cloud
and run it for you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So when it
comes for you to actually build
that software, how
do you create it such
that it's available
for everybody?
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yeah,
so there are actually
three answers to that.
So, first, we have,
of course, the model.
So what we do is we
created a pipeline that
trains the model in
separate languages.
So Weaviate comes
in eight languages.
What we do, it starts on GitHub,
where the source code lives.
And when we make
changes, or when
we want to create a new model--
because, of course, the data
that we're getting in
is also-- for example,
Wikipedia is also
constantly growing.
We push that to Google Cloud.
We train on CPUs.
That has to do with the type
of model that we're using.
In seconds, we spin up this
tremendously huge machine.
I think we're talking
many dozens of CPUs.
We're talking about, I
think, 800 gigs of memory.
And it starts to
pull in all the data
sources, hundreds of
gigabytes of source material.
It does the preprocessing,
it does the training.
It compresses all of that into,
I think, in between 1 and 1/2
and 2 gigabytes of a model,
pushes it to Docker Hub,
shuts everything
down, and we're done.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: How would
you say Google Cloud has
helped you build that?
BOB VAN LUIJT: So there
are two answers to that.
So, first is more
the-- on a high level.
Building this five
years ago, maybe--
I mean, especially
10 years ago--
maybe even five years ago
would've been impossible.
I mean, it's just
impossible to do it.
So these dozens of CPUs,
that amount of memory--
it would simply be impossible.
So we are a small company.
We're a startup, and
we can just build this.
And not even just once--
we can do it every month.
So the fact that these
tools are available to us
just at the click of a button
or a command in the command
line, that is fantastic.
More practically,
that is the way
how Google Cloud has
organized the infrastructure.
So we use the APIs
and G Cloud a lot.
So.
In batch scripts,
we use G Cloud.
And in other situations,
we use the API ecosystem.
It's just-- it's very
straightforward and very easy
to use.
It's very easy to debug, to
understand what's going well,
what's going wrong, releases
of underlying technologies
like operating systems-- that
just comes all out of the box.
So it's just-- if I just tried
to think how we would have--
should have done this five or
10 years ago, that's just--
that's impossible, I think.
So that's how it helps us.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We
talked earlier about
how people can use Weaviate.
They can use the hosted
model or they can set it up.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What were
the next steps for people
who are really interested in
learning more about Weaviate.
BOB VAN LUIJT: So they
can go to our website.
That would by be
SeMI.technology.
Then they can find the
documentation button,
and that's basically where
they can get started.
We are represented
on all platforms--
Stack Overflow,
GitHub, Twitter--
well, anything that
you can think about.
So-- and if people have
questions or want to engage,
then I'm looking
forward to meeting them.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
it's really exciting
to hear about this space.
So thank you very much
for coming in, Bob.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]